el viaje turístico que terminó en
tragedia italia entró en conmoción este
domingo cuando un teleférico cayó al
vacío
ward y ver que un cable está roto dos
excursionistas dijeron que esta mañana
escucharon un gran silbido y vieron este
teleférico que estaba casi en la cima y
de repente retrocedió rápido y cuando
golpeó el pilón chocó creo que dos veces
en este terreno empinado y finalmente se
detuvo contra dos pinos
a la cabina que conecta las estaciones
de destreza y mottarone que hay un
bosque producto del desprendimiento de
un cable y el fallar los mecanismos de
seguridad dijeron las autoridades
locales todo por la salud oa camino días
después de la caída dado que es muy
empinado el teleférico rodó unas decenas
de metros hasta que se estrelló con dos
grandes árboles el teleférico
accidentado se encontraba a 300 metros
de la estación de llegada en uno de los
puntos más altos de la montaña tras los
meses de restricciones por pandemia
reabrió sus puertas en abril como una
medida contra el kobe 19 sólo permitía
abordar a 15 pasajeros cuando antes
podía trasladar hasta 40 el teleférico
fue cerrado en 2014 para ser revisado y
reabrió en 2016 tras varias obras que
costaron alrededor de 4 millones de
euros mientras las operaciones de
rescate continúan las autoridades han
prometido una investigación judicial y
revisan las instalaciones los encargados
sostienen que la cabina se encontraba en
excelente estado